valerian is full of
well
bull
from annoying characters to overpowered
abilities and stupid maps valerian is
full of things that the community loves
to hate so this week we want to take a
look at what riot really got wrong with
their tactical shooter but before we
start i just will make sure you are sub
to the channel so hit the subscribe
button hit the notification bell and
buckle up because today we are counting
down the top 10 most broken
bullet
in valor in history
kicking off our list is something so
broken that it didn't even make it out
of beta it's razer's grenades that's
right i said grenades as in plural
i think he's right side
he's in midsole
this character is stupid
kit was generally overpowered back in
the beta but the biggest problem was her
grenades see back then reyes had two
grenades that could rip through teams so
easily she made valerian look like a
utility dumping simulator luckily riot
decided to nerf rays just before launch
removing one of her paint shells and
instead changing it so that she gets
another grenade after a player secures
two kills and sure she's less broken now
but reyes is still capable of some
outrageous plays paranoia is going to
have to be wasted on this
oh
he is the triple off the rocket is the
fourth kill he's working on the ac
that's an absolutely monstrous
performance there on short a looking
for the last player
in our number nine spot we have
something that has plagued ballard since
day one
running and gunning
the aim penalty for moving while
shooting is so insignificant that
running and gunning with the phantom
inspector is actually a viable option
plus since there are no distinct spray
patterns invalerant gunplay can
sometimes feel pretty unrewarding simply
put dying to a stray bullet from
somebody running around a corner is
infuriating
you think so
1000
how do i do that
riot nerfed running gunning back in june
but honestly it wasn't enough moving and
shooting still works way too well
coming in at number eight is day one
killjoy who could annihilate you with
her alarmbot molly combo i'm so dead
here i can't see
your mind's open right now
on launch kiljoy's turret and alarmbot
were active regardless of how far she
got from them this meant that your team
could essentially stack an entire site
and leave killjoy's utility on the other
side of the map to hold things down for
you
thankfully after a lot of outrage riot
proceeded to nerf her mollies and change
the rest of her kit so it would no
longer be active if she moved more than
40 meters away from them today kiljoy is
nowhere near as oppressive as she used
to be but those first few weeks were
hell
sliding into the number 7 spot is a map
that was the single most hated thing in
all of valram back when it was released
you know we're talking about icebox
if it's icebox i'm gonna i'm gonna
puke in my mouth
with an insane amount of angles to clear
attacking either of icebox sites was a
nightmare
this combined with the long rotations
made it nearly impossible to sell a fake
long rotation it's hard to fake stuff
there's a lot of like high elevation um
generally maps of high elevation don't
get liked because yes there's not a lot
of like uh
vertical crosshair movement icebox was
so bad when it came out that we made an
entire video about the community's
hatred towards it but riot recently made
some changes to the map making it easier
for teams to attack b site so you don't
have to worry about getting shot through
the same box every time you try to plant
slowing her way into the number six spot
we have sage who like many agents was
pretty broken upon release back then
sage's wall had 1 000 health completely
shutting down any sort of sight hit with
ease sure you could break it with
bullets or your knife but on pistol
rounds that meant wasting precious
seconds and basically all of your ammo
on one stupid wall her wall could last
up to 40 seconds and with two slow orbs
that lasted nine seconds each sage could
basically lock down a single section of
the map for most of her around at this
point riots basically nerfed all of
sage's abilities and nowadays she's
balanced
mostly
absolutely terrible okay resurrection
gonna be used and this time it's sick to
fall instead of shazam so the blade
storm still available shazam goes up top
he is eventually gonna fall again that's
two deaths on the round and yay over the
top resurrection traded and and box are
not giving this one up
it looks flawless it looks like an ace
because that's exactly what it was
coming in at our number five spot is one
of the most obnoxious metas in
ballerin's history
the stinger meta
assange defending very close oh
asana that is insane with the stinger
the hip fire spread on this weapon was
extremely tight and with its high rate
of fire you were able to laser opponents
from ridiculous distances in a lot of
situations it was as good as a rifle
meaning everyone was buying cheap
stingers instead of phantoms and vandals
eventually riot nerfed the gun's bullet
spread and rate of fire making the gun
more or less usable
flying into the number 4 spot we have
one of the most bs abilities in the
entire game
skye's flash
[Applause]
these damn birds have been turning
player screens white since sky was
released but beyond the annoying flash
the most broken part of this ability is
that skye actually tells you if it hit
an enemy that's right you get free
information on top of a wicked flash
meaning that she can pop a flash through
smokes and take aggressive duels no
other agent can
every other flash character has to
strategically decide when they want to
use their utility because if they go in
on a bad flash they die but skye is
brain dead you can just mindlessly flash
through a smoke or around a corner hear
the word blinded and you have all the
info you need talk about balance
in our number three spot we have one of
the most broken weapons in the entire
game the classic
okay
one enemy remaining oh my god spike down
mid
i went for another right click because i
was just feeling it the classics right
click shoots three bullets
simultaneously with a pretty tight
spread but the biggest issue is its
jumping accuracy turns out you can brain
people while jumping with this stupid
pistol meaning you're spamming shots and
dodging enemies with little risk oh and
did we mention that this is a free gun
the shark starts being bounced around
eco trying to pre-fire this position oh
right click no way eco he stopped oh
he's going so three
oh my god what a round from hiko the
classic was finally nerfed once again in
patch 3.09 making the firing error while
running and jumping much more
significant this is the nerf that the
community was begging for but only time
will tell if it's enough
coming in at our runner-up spot is the
single most overpowered [ __ ] gun
valerian has ever produced so far
the judge
but uh nonetheless
he's gonna leading
the judge is supposed to be an auto
shotgun but the range on this thing is
absolutely ridiculous you can spam shots
off from across the map and clean up
your opponents with ease help back in
march a controller wielding cipher one
trick even managed to hit rank 22 on the
n a server just from abusing this one
busted weapon
no way
i was not ready for this
ah yes
oh my god that's the controller cipher
riot nerfed the judge's range damage and
even its price but this hasn't stopped
players like das nurse from dominating
the game with it simply put the judge is
still very much broken
one enemy remaining
despite countless nerfs jets still
remains the single most broken agent in
the entire game which is why she takes
the number one spot on her list riot has
nerfed her smokes her updraft her ult
and even the cost of her abilities but
jet still reigns supreme
why
because riot hasn't touched the one
ability that makes her so damn
oppressive
her dash
could potentially catch up with the
thieves of god just like cnet will find
steel inside shop jet's tailwind ability
allows her to take aggressive peaks with
an operator and get in and out of tight
situations without getting punished and
even after the nerfs jet still remains
the only agent that could reliably carry
it off
the
the gun the op is only viable on jet and
that's a problem in my opinion riot
accidentally fixed jet when the patch
broke her dash and forced her to take
her gun out again whenever it ended but
unfortunately
it got hotfixed
so until ry decides to actually do
something about her dash on purpose jet
will continue to terrorize ranked games
everywhere
well folks that's our list if you think
you missed anything let us know down in
the comment section below take care and
i'll see you in the next one
i'll sit
you up now
oh my god
jesus christ
it's just that's just ego
oh my god
they never fake okay i will all be with
my camera
142 race 10 hp
what the [ __ ] is that peakman
you have to be kidding me